regarder les étoiles filantes ont
vieilli déclin 21 ans vous fassiez
c'est un dessin animé qui sont son
univers son charme ses personnages sont
pleins d'humanité c'est ce qui manque un
peu dans le monde d'aujourd'hui donc ça
fait du bien de voir des gens qui
s'entraident
c'est le plus gros de tous les
astéroïdes
il faut faire une voix un peu différente
de la vôtre tout en conservant l'énergie
de la vôtre quand même il faut trouver
une réponse à ses partenaires qui ne
sont pas présents le jour vous le faites
et donc tous ces petits détails font que
vous inquiéter mais finalement on se
retrouve au niveau de ses personnages en
deux en deux boucles
on va tous disparaître bug insecte avec
vous a dit la solution vous voyez là où
les autres vécu au rythme il ya un truc
exceptionnel c'est les yeux les regards
parce qu'on travaille là dessus en tout
cas pour mon personnage à moi manille où
la trompe
évidemment cache la bouche donc il est
très expressif avec ses yeux et c'est
lui qui m'indique les solutions chercher
des indices cosmique et trouver le moyen
d'arrêter
ces crétins pour croire qu'il peut
arrêter un objet envie de cracher dit
toujours prêt en cas de besoin la
gestuelle est importante c'est à dire
que on se remet dans les patins de
l'énergie c'est pour ça qu'on fait de la
gestuelle c'est pas parce qu'on est
envahie du personnage parce qu'à un
moment il va falloir trouver un souffle
particulier une action particulière un
effort à faire voilà donc c'est pour ça
qu'on bouge cependant que vous prendrez
vos pâtes à moscou nous on sera peinard
là haut dans le ciel tous en sécurité
comme ces oiseaux
ouais enfin presque ok misère je vois
par rapport à ce père qui est très très
proche de sa fille la manière dont ils
appréhendent la vie avec elle pour
l'instant elle n'est amoureuse que de
lui et lui de la même manière sauf qu'un
jour elle partira en mobylette aussi
avec un autre amoureux avec une petite
fille il est bien évident que on a des
rapports tendres donc que c'était très
heureux de voir manny devenir papa mais
à partir du moment où elle a décidé de
se marier et qui a un gendre possible
dans la famille qui va rentrer là il ya
chez manie une espèce de stress parce
qu'au départ il n'est pas du tout
d'accord bien évidemment se fiancer est
un concurrent fondamentale
il va falloir que ce personnage du
gendre de vienne idéal pour l'instant il
ne l'est pas du tout on veut c'est
réaliser le mien aussi